[Applause]
[Music]
February is behind us which means this
episode of new releases is taking a
top-down look at the month of March the
new month brings us a bunch of entries
in some beloved series for everyone from
action junkies to sports fans in fact
there's so much that this episode
includes a bonus sixth recommendation so
let's jump right into some of the
hottest games coming in March the month
kicks off with pokemon mystery dungeon
rescue team DX you may recall red and
blue rescue teams on the original DS and
this new deluxe version includes all the
content from both dressed in a new
spiffy-looking watercolor inspired art
style you'll fight and turn-based
battles as you explore the game's many
dungeons but rather than catch new
monsters and pokeballs
you'll be recruiting them onto your
rescue team this re-release even
includes mega evolutions it's coming
exclusively to switch on Friday March
6th but you can download a demo from the
eShop right now you can also go
exploring in Ori and the will of the
wisps which makes some pretty
significant changes from the first game
this sequel trades the manual checkpoint
system for auto-saves
and instead of purchasing sequential
upgrades you'll collect shards to spend
on various abilities and items but you
can still expect the same level of
Metroidvania exploration in combat as
you go beyond the forest of the first
game the adventure begins on Xbox one
and PC on Wednesday the 11th and yes it
will be available on game paths
March has another sequel that's changing
things up with neo 2 this game is
actually set before the events of neo so
you'll be creating a custom character
instead of controlling William Adams
you'll still have to switch stances and
maintain your stamina and health as you
battle big bosses but this time around
you can take them on and three player
co-op what's more you can actually
transform into a youkai yourself if you
acquire a monster's soul core neo 2 is a
ps4 exclusive launching Friday the 13th
here's hoping we get a new Twitter
stance as DLC after that
let's trade our samurai swords for
baseball bats with another ps4 exclusive
MLB the show 20 last year's game
included the minor leagues but not any
of the actual players this time the
minor league players likenesses are
actually included team and logo editing
is also moving to franchise mode before
this you could only use it in diamond
dynasty you can see the changes for
yourself on Tuesday the 17th I don't
know if Animal Crossing New Horizons has
baseball but it does have plenty of
other outdoor activities for you to
enjoy the latest entry in the cutesy
series is set on an island one that you
can actually terraform to your liking
using the new Nook phone there's almost
too much new stuff to even list here
from new animal friends to seasonal
updates to finally being able to
customize your villager from the start
it's all happening only on switch on
Friday the 20th that same day we're
getting a game on the total opposite end
of the spectrum doom eternal there's a
lot of new stuff to talk about in this
sequel to like the doom Slayers
grappling hook and flamethrower which
add even more chaos to the game's
frenetic combat there's also an
asymmetrical multiplayer mode where one
Slayer takes on two player controlled
demons speaking of which there are
plenty of new demons to take on in the
campaign - including the tomb hunter and
Marauder doom eternal hits ps4 xbox one
pc and stadia on the 20th with a switch
version planned for later this year and
those are some of the hottest games
launching all month long as always
remember that release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change thanks for watching guys and I'll
be back with a deeper look at more March
games next Sunday